nous avons de très bons politiciens nous
avons devait le nous avons deux salles
et ben maire nous avons de vivre nous
avons des pêcheurs
le bon pêcheur nous avons quelques
bergers qui nous reste nous avons là mme
koch qui est ouverte et surtout je
connais le montagne sur la plage est ça
commence tous ses bikinis et toutes ces
choses là qu envoyer ces belges et vieux
qui ont 70 80 ans qui voit sa d'essayer
si ma femme vous voyez charme à leur
double entre les auvergnats pour elle
les chante rien regarde quand même alors
rien a dit mais pourquoi tu regardes dit
écoute
jeanne cherhal est en moi je ne peux pas
lui
[Musique]
à
oh
et
à
allez
[Musique]
au madame si vous étiez venu à celle
donnée à 30 ans c'était l'arbre d'hélice
à ce moment là n'avait pas toute sa vie
la tanesco présent aux fruits depuis
1956 il ya plus de 200 constructions
seconde alors qu'avant il s'y adonne
même laventie part il y avait
une école à brûlante
il y avait
un petit restaurant
et aux quatre maisons
actuellement au fond long ça change des
plages étaient toujours vidé les
personnes
hébergées c'était un plaisir y avait au
moins 30 de bergers qui ont disparu
depuis
est ce que vous croyez que les gens sont
plus heureux maintenant ils sont plus
malheureux parce qu'à présent avant vous
arriviez un corse se faisait un plaisir
de vous héberger et on se disputait à
l'honneur de vous avoir à table à
présent sur le rite halal et sont peu
comme les autres commencent à se gâter
l'argent et je crois qu'à du même poteau
il ya eu encore récemment
un crime d'honneur h à madame service
est affaire de famille qui se
débrouillent entre
ces choses là balmain
n'existe pas de tuer quelqu'un à la
maison mais en vain
les choses délicates
et crimes crimes et se consomme dans les
gifler voulez vous devez envoyer une
balle voilà quand le chèque de retour au
lien voit une balle comment vous avez
été mêlé à la faire renaître d'un parent
d'un cousin jamais vous savez fallait
défendre la famille toujours dans le
droit de l'honneur quand elle a voulu
faire un petit show de côté il ya fait
contrainte est vraiment nette alors
vraiment quelqu'un qu'on a encore abîmé
monsieur untel gagner ces élections
monsieur notre hôtel sollicité et des
gens non sont très connus au bogota par
l'hygiène c'est qu'ils venaient ici
encore jeu le pavillon soient menés par
le bateau j'étais gül en voyage balayage
à chaud par le bateau surtout quand la
mer était mauvaise il venait historicité
j'étais des rencontres dans le maquis
avec le gala
du champagne avait des bons vins corses
et tout et tout et tout après il ya eu
des histoires de femmes parce que les
femmes lui courait après ça les femmes
de la terrible ça dirai combien de temps
auch a duré
[Musique]
quinze 15 ans par là il a réussi 15 ans
à garder leur chien couché dans les ados
lien
et puis alors là c'est vraiment nette
avait une forme du baldy et huit
formules banditisme bien à lui d'un type
très intelligent
il était passé en guinée elle n'avait
pas qu'il avait compris qu'il ne
pourrait pas tuer un par le plaisir du
meurtre alors il fait il ya des affaires
il a même fait du cinéma comment est-ce
qu'il a été pris elle a été punie
coucher comme d'habitude attiré 1
kw h vote in à bout portant
pas senti chantier enfin c'est bien loin
tout ça oui j'ai heureusement pour la
corde mais rien ne changeait
autour du 28
[Musique]
août c'est
tous les jours dans tous les jours il ya
beaucoup plus de monde dans les t
[Musique]
bonds soleil
cette retraitée je ne fais rien vous ne
faites rien vous êtes heureux comme ça
passe assez bien de voir un homme
heureux c'est comme ça qu'est ce que
vous faites est joliment qui comprend
bachelot
je ne sais plus
toujours à cause de la main d'oeuvre
pourquoi il n'y a pas de mandat
je vous souhaite les gens partent les
jeunes partent et n'y a plus de vie dans
les villages se paye ce jeu mes trucs
tous
quelques kilomètres dans un ménage qui
faisait
encore 200 habitants il ya une quinzaine
d'années qui nous fait chaud qu'est ce
qui va se passer maintenant change pas
chez toi
ça me branche est un braqueur les
ménages vont mourir
triste ça non en revanche et à quelques
petites constructions qui chevaux les
gens qui viennent cacher les conduit à
temps plein
ou bien qu'ils ouvrent la chose en vue
de leur retraite future c'est pas la
vraie vie ce 1 c'est pas la vraie vie ça
dans la vraie vie c'est pas la valve et
économique parce que tout mort vraiment
autour de certaines sont pas loin du
poteau qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'on
pourrait faire j'ai bien
très peu de choses
[Musique]
à qui appartient ce moulin à huile
lorient famille qu'est ce que vous
faites à par l'apôtre participation dans
le manager vous êtes restaurateur et
vous monsieur moi je suis fonctionnaire
et vous monsieur boucher et vous êtes
vous habitez olmeto oui ton lait froid
oui vous êtes originaire dans le métro
oui et qu'est ce que faisait votre père
à l'origine il était boucher s'est
installé à olmeto congo chez il est
hébergé toute hâte au début
et ensuite quand il s'est marié il s'est
installé boucher à olmeto mon père avait
acheté un petit pressoir à huile qui
fonctionnait au au mulet et nous avons
perfectionné ça parce qu'il fallait le
faire
sinon les unes se peler les olives se
perdaient et il n'y avait plus
moyenne de les cueillir et de l'est
les critiques les habitants du village
nous amène les olives les olives sont
vêtus les et nous rendons l'huile aux
différentes personnes qui nous ont
rapporté sept îles il ressemble le
ventre nous vendons une partie de
l'huile
à l'habitant au
risque et quelquefois si la quantité
assez importante
nous les sports nous laisse portant sur
le continent au dessus du moulin à huile
et à un dancing
et à l'hectare supérieur à 1 restera
[Musique]
ici l'agriculture se transforme au
détriment des bergers
[Musique]
des 275 mille moutons la corse possédait
en 1949 il n'en reste aujourd'hui que
120 milieu des deux cent mille chèvre
40000 seul
dans la montagne les agents des ptt
utilise encore des moyens de transport
que l'on croyait depuis longtemps
disparu
pourtant ici l'état des routes c'est
bien d'améliorer
le problème des transports ont fait une
très nette amélioration dans la corse
avaient leur réseau routier le plus
étendu et le plus mauvais état et depuis
deux ans il ya vraiment des réalisations
spectaculaires et je pense que cet
effort sera poursuivi
jusqu'à ce que au moins les les
principaux axes
soit entièrement refaits élargie soit
roulant comme le portion qui ont été
construites maintenance et sincère et le
chemin de fer et bien il faut que nous
conservions notre chemin de fer vous
savez que les corps sont très attachés à
leur chemin de fer peut-être un petit
peu parce que il est bientôt centenaire
mais sympa tellement ça c'est parce
qu'ils rendent d'énormes services qu'on
le veuille ou non c'est l'hiver lorsque
les injections sont enfermés le dos
tourné aux montagnes qui sont enneigées
qu'ils sont du côté qu'il regarde du
côté de la mer si l'ua fois à l'air
bastien très souvent les voitures ne
passent pas où passent difficilement
local de vie de savone les autocars le
passera difficilement ou pas du tout
l'autorail parce que moi je pense qu'on
traque lui confère un très gros efforts
pour améliorer le réseau ferré en tout
cas ce qu'il faudrait pour le tourisme
accord sur lequel on parle tant il
faudrait que le parisien qui publie un
corse puis se prendre un passage sur les
bateaux de la compagnie transatlantique
marseille avec la même facilité qui
prend son billet chemin de fer à la gare
de lyon à la gare de l'est tels
problèmes de l'été lui même est assez
restreint il est élu il existe il ne
faut pas s'il ne faut pas se le
dissimuler c'est un fait
nous n'arrivons pas à faire face
entièrement à la demande et il serait
malhonnête de ma part de le nier le
matériel que nous utilisons sur la corse
est à la pointe de la technique on dit
toujours le monopole et qu'est ce que
c'est exactement le monopole eh bien
vous avez d'une part le monopole de
pavillons qui résulte de l'application
de l'article 257 du code des douanes qui
réservent le trafic contreportes
français au pavillon france deuxième
aspect de ce qu'on appelle le monopole
c'est le fait que nous ayons une
convention avec l'état nous sommes dans
la pratique les seuls à assurer le
transport des passagers
entre les ports du continent français et
les protos
cette convention c'est la compagnie
transméditerranéenne filiale de la
compagnie générale transatlantique qui
on bénéficie charge pour elle d'assurer
les liaisons en toute saison y compris
les périodes creuses quels sont les
grands problèmes de la corse à la
actuelle
il y en a beaucoup sont toujours les
mêmes et à l'emploi bien sûr
l emploi qui est une question très
délicate mais je ne sais pas tellement
vous dire ce qu'il en est des voix plus
autorisées que moi vous le diront
certainement il ya beaucoup de choses il
y à l'insularité
il ya la difficulté des changes avec le
continent il y à la vie chère lui plus
cher parce que nous sommes les
insulaires à bastia par lebouc ou de
scinder la corse en deux départements
qu'est ce qu'on pense à un ajaccien
un ajaccien un moyen ne pense que ce
serait probablement une erreur à mon
humble avis je
je suis sûr qu'avec
le tempérament
les tempéraments différents entre ceux
de l'au-delà démon c'est à dire la
région d'ajaccio rico et ceux de l'an de
sa démo il ya déjà une différence énorme
la corse est faite
de caractères très différents de régions
différentes les cap corse la balagne la
côte ouest le sartenais et avec ses
différences elles forment quand même une
unique je pense que serais je les ai
déjà dit une erreur parce qu'à ce moment
là s'il y avait deux départements nous
vivrions vraiment le dos tourné les ans
les autres c'est une question qui est
tout à fait à la mode on en parle depuis
quelques années c'est parti depuis
depuis cette année c'est partie de
bastia la jeune chambre économique
notamment je crois qu'il ya de bonnes
idées il est certain qu'on souffre
notamment à bastia qui est la ville
commerciale et industrielle par le plus
important de corse on souffre de
l'éloignement de l'administration
régionale essentiellement concentrée à
ajaccio
ceci dit est ce que la
bidépartementalisation
solution à nos problèmes est ce que cela
nous apportera plus de crédit mais
difficile de me prononcer sur cette
question là je crois qu'il ya des
avantages et des inconvénients
le conseil général sagement à proposer
de faire un référendum en corse auprès
des populations intéressées je crois
qu'à ce moment là on vers un petit peu
ce qui va ressortir de ce référendum
encore vivant quand ce que vous voyez
vous l'avenir de la corse il ya
plusieurs façons de le voir et on peut
être pessimiste on peut être optimiste
selon quand
on pense qu'on va subir qu'on va agir
comme d'habitude réalité certainement ça
entre les deux tourisme artisanat
industrialisation intellectualisation où
va-t-on de toute façon ce à quoi nous
voudrions aller et ça je crois que
personne ne pourra le contester c'est
vers le bonheur
est ce que le bonheur c'est l'argent
il semble que non depuis longtemps le
dit que l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
mais d'autre part on ne peut pas nier
que la vie que nous vivons actuellement
composée d'un certain nombre de choses
ces choses sinon nous ne tenons pas
compte ne sont pas des gens réalistes
donc nous n'avons plus rien à espérer il
nous sommes que la corse et dieu merci
en retard et par ce retard reste une
espèce doazit ce pas toujours intacte
complètement et à tous les endroits en
particulier c'est très sensible au
niveau des paysages niveau de certaines
réactions des hommes qui se détériore
petit à petit sommes quand même tous les
pas perdus et est ce qu'il est possible
de supposer que dans la mesure où tout
n'est pas perdu à partir de ce qui
existe encore on puisse bâtir quelque
chose qui tienne compte de tout ce que
représente la vie moderne avec tous ces
avantages tous ces inconvénients c'est
en quelque sorte le pari que nous
faisons est ce qu'il est justifié est-ce
qu'il réussira à ça je crois que
l'avenir seul le dira de toute façon
c'est à la fois notre intérêt et notre
plaisir de tenter
[Musique]